no like tell me because obviously you
um
you've been rapping how many years has
it been
I wrote my first round when I was eight
but for your first time like you dropped
an actual project oh
officially oh yeah
oh not hell not in that's the case
by 2013. um
yeah 2013 I probably uploaded my first
song to SoundCloud
damn so you're like low-key you've been
doing this [__] you ain't you ain't like
a you're a new artist but you're not a
new artist not at all I've been grinding
I don't seen
like I don't see in a lot of different
eras in this music [__] you feel me you
gotta think like I was born in 2000 you
know what I'm saying when 2 000 hit who
was popping
[__] Nellie 50 Nelly no I'm saying so by
the time 2002 you able to talking you
know what I'm saying my mama told me
[__] I was able to
ghost Audi it's your birthday you know
I'm saying that whole song that was two
years old it's getting hot in here take
off all your clothes I know this [__] my
mama told me she said you know I was you
know I'm saying I was meant for this
[__] you know what I'm saying just
thought that you were two years old
singing two years old like you know how
to learn that [__] yeah you know how
that [__] go you two years old you hit a
little song popping in yeah so I'm
pretty sure she did that right is there
a you say you've seen a lot of Errors of
hip-hop what era do you miss the most
that's a good question I probably missed
that
what year I was when when Wayne dropped
like Hustler music I was awake no it was
customer music was Cardiff too yes
you're you're so that was like
2006. I said I go back there when you
were six years old yeah I'd probably go
better there when I was like when 106
apart was heavy and all that and Lil
Wayne Lil Wayne the purple you remember
who you like who's your favorite host
because there are so many iterations of
106 and Park hosts I got to go original
probably AJ and free AJ and freeze the I
mean that's for sure I don't even
remember who I was hosting I think Big
Tigger hosted it for a little bit yeah I
just know I hosted it a little bit and
then Bow Wow hosted it that's right
Terence J Terence was good too shots of
Terrence I forgot about Bow Wow I feel
like for a little bit when they were
when they hosted two when I was a little
kid I thought a little bow wow owned 106
and Park like I thought he just had some
steak in it because he was on that
[__] yeah shout out and little
Romeo it's crazy how about I keep coming
up man I've been paying about my hummus
to buy people looked at me like I was
crazy you know what I'm saying because I
was paying how much power are they like
now but I'm telling me I like about all
the reason I'm here during this
interview like come on if you want to be
technical bro that man bro I'm you got a
thing I just told you I don't see you
everywhere now you got a thing I'm
watching a little bow I don't want to
sits apart like damn I can do that [__]
I'm gonna do that one day so Bow Wow
Come on one of the reasons you feel me
the show for sure you know it's
inspiration got it till hey Bow Wow Loki
I would say we gotta put a little more
respect on Bow Wow's name
pull it up in that Bentley on on fresh
as I miss video come on gotta go get me
one it's actually my favorite Bow Wow I
gotta go get me one of them what was the
other one where he did the awkward like
let me hold you was that that was like
all right let me hold you yeah I told
myself then if you can do it I can do it
[__] that's it that's fair